[Applaus]
[Musik]
der zweite dezember 2010 wache das
emirat katar ein glorreiches datum an
diesem tag bekam das kleine land am
persischen golf den zuschlag für die
ausrichtung der
fußball-weltmeisterschaft 2022 von der
fifa den internationalen verband des
einflussreichsten sport der welt eine
entscheidung die für katar eines der
reichsten länder der welt den start
eines der größten investitionsprogramme
seiner geschichte bedeutet was sage ich
seiner geschichte der geschichte
überhaupt ja wir reden hier vorne hat
sich jetzt bitte fest von fast 200
milliarden dollar wahnsinn so viel geld
nur so ein kickerturnier
nun natürlich steht nicht alles aus
dieser enorme summe in direktem
zusammenhang mit der wm viel mehr war
dieses ereignis der perfekte vorwand für
die katarische regierung um einen großen
plan zur modernisierung des emirats
voranzutreiben es geht also nicht nur um
moderne fußballstadien für welche die
katarische regierung rund sechs
milliarden dollar ausgeben wird sondern
auch neue autobahn und eisenbahnlinien
ein 300 kilometer langes probahn es dass
fast 40 milliarden dollar kostet oder
den ausbau des hammad airport zu einem
der modernsten größten und luxuriösesten
flughäfen der welt
mit anderen worten die
fußball-weltmeisterschaft 2022 ist in
den augen der regierung hat fast eine
art wendepunkt für das land der anbruch
einer neuen ära der moderne und des
wohlstands das kassette sahnehäubchen
für eine wirtschaft die sich seit der
jahrhundertwende fast verzehnfacht hat
und dieses kleine emirat zu einem der
reichsten länder der welt gemacht habt
ja katar 2022 klingt wie ein wahr
gewordenes märchen aus tausendundeiner
nacht nicht wahr dann steht diese mega
event der riesen party des jahres mit
welcher die welt diese scheinbar
vorbildliche gastgeber nation und die
kataris sich selbst feiern werden ja
nichts mehr im weg was nur könnte diese
idylle den trüben nun eine ganze menge
alle möglichen verdächtigungen und eine
riesige welle der kritik haben sich auch
um diese weltmeisterschaft gebildet so
sehr dass viele internationale
organisationen sie inzwischen als
weltmeisterschaft der schande bezeichnen
das alles hat uns bei visual politik
veranlasst ein paar fragen zu stellen
warum in aller welt ist katar überhaupt
so erpicht darauf eine fußball
weltmeisterschaft auszurichten warum
hält es diese für eine so große sache
und von welchen verdächtigungen ist die
rede was steckt dahinter bleibt dran
denn in diesem video werden wir all
diese fragen beantworten und zwar gleich
nach dem für die ganz kurz unserem
sponsor circuit vorgestellt haben der
dieses video möglich gemacht hat bei
surf art handelt es sich um ein wirklich
sicheres vpn dass weder datenverkehr
noch meter oder verbindungsdaten mit
lockt natürlich könnt ihr mit dessen
hilfe auch webseiten und internet
dienste zugreifen die in dem land in die
wir gerade seid nicht verfügbar sind
ohne zensur und theo blocking ob daheim
oder im urlaub netflix und andere
streaming dienste die ihre inhalte nur
in den usa anbieten von europa aus
nutzen mit soft kein problem darüber
hinaus bietet es jedoch auch eine menge
sicherheitsfeatures hat ja nicht zum
beispiel auch ein mulmiges gefühl durch
die allgegenwärtigen werbe popups und
coupés mit surft bekommt ihr ein
handliches tool namens klien wird dass
sie eine blockt und die damit
verbundenen gefahren beseitigt aber
nicht nur das mit nur einem server kommt
könnt ihr alle eure geräte im vpn
registrieren handys notebooks oder sogar
irgendwie v effekt wirklich alle arten
von geräten auf ihr bekommt einen
lückenlosen schutz so und damit das
ganze noch mehr spaß macht bekommt ihr
von cirque auch noch einen rabatt von
83% und obendrein noch die ersten zehn
monate gratis dazu wenn ihr den
rabattcode politik.de angebt denn links
zu diesem angebot findet ihr in der
beschreibung unter diesem video also
nichts wie los besorgt euch vorschlag
und greift damit gleich um uns
finanziell unter die arme das könnt ihr
übrigens auch direkt mit hilfe eines
paypal spenden links den ich euch
ebenfalls in die beschreibung gepackt
haben wir sind euch für jede
unterstützung dankbar denn damit hält
wir uns euch in zukunft noch mehr und
noch bessere videos zu liefern so und
jetzt nichts wie ab an den persischen
golf
die macht des sports
[Musik]
machen wir uns nichts vor viele dinge
haben sich enorm verbessert vielleicht
viel viel mehr als wir uns noch vor ein
paar jahren hätten vorstellen können
aber die wahrheit ist dass die staaten
am persischen golf trotz aller
fortschritte sehr starke und im grunde
noch immer tyrannische regimes mit
vielen einschränkungen der grundlegenden
menschenrechte geblieben sind also ich
meine auch ohne corona dafür zu brauchen
und wisst ihr was aus dieser perspektive
ist die sogenannte sport diplomatie zu
einer säule der politischen strategie
jedes dieser regimes geworden und dafür
gibt es vier wesentliche gründe erstens
weil der sport diesen ländern ermöglicht
trotz der massiven diskriminierung von
frauen lg pittis und viele ausländer und
kriterien listen nach außen ein ganz
anderes image zu verkaufen ein bild der
modernität des wettbewerbs des erfolgs
alles sehr positive attribute es gibt
für diese überaus beliebte heuchlerische
praxis sogar einen eigenen namen sports
vor shane ja ganz analog zum green
washing das von vielen konzern betrieben
wird pr methoden die darauf abzielen
eine unternehmen in der öffentlichkeit
ein umweltfreundliches und
verantwortungsbewusstes image zu
verleihen ohne dass es dafür eine reale
grundlage gibt statt der umwelt müssen
in diesem fall aber eben sportwettkämpfe
als marketing vehikel herhalten
der zweite grund besteht ganz einfach
darin dass diese länder dank des sports
ganz allgemeinen vielen der
internationale bekanntheit erlangen
können und dadurch mehr einfluss
erlangen katar ist hierfür das
paradebeispiel ein land das seit jahren
in angst vor einer saudischen invasion
lebt wenn du regelmäßig visual politik
schaust weißt du wahrscheinlich schon
dass sowohl saudi arabien als auch die
vereinigten arabischen emirate sich
nicht besonders gut mit qatar verstehen
und es liegt ja auf der hand die
bekannte ein land ist je besser sein
internationales image und je mehr
einfluss es hat desto schwieriger wird
es für ein anderes land seien es
unbemerkt von der weltöffentlichkeit zu
überfallen es ist etwas ähnliches wie
das was viele russische oligarch schon
viele jahre lang taten um sich vor dem
zorn des kremls zu schützen die bekannte
sie in der öffentlichkeit waren desto
schwieriger war es die in staden kost zu
nehmen bis dann irgendwann auch der
wendepunkt dieser strategie kam
[Musik]
der dritte grund katar ist wie fast alle
länder am persischen golf sehr stark von
der erdöl und erdgasförderung abhängig
ist genau aus diesem grund versuchen sie
seit jahren ihre wirtschaft zu
diversifizieren nun auch hierbei kann
der sport eine sehr wichtige rolle
spielen sowohl zur förderung des
tourismus als auch für die entwicklung
anderer wirtschaftsaktivitäten es gibt
zum beispiel die fälle von wie in sports
und abu dhabi sports zwei großen fernseh
produktions übertragungs plattformen die
eine ganze industrie von journalisten
analysten programmierern und werde
experten aus dem boden gestampft haben
die us boys zum beispiel besitzt
fernsehrechte für viele der größten
wettbewerber der welt und der vierte
grund nun ganz einfach weil sie es sich
leisten können wenn du berge von geld
hast willst du es ja schließlich auch
für etwas verwenden oder zum beispiel um
bei den größten events die hauptrolle zu
spielen
[Musik]
tatsache ist dass die länder am
persischen golf aus all diesen gründen
in den letzten jahren stark auf sport
gesetzt haben sie schufen nationale
ligen und trainingszentren sie ziehen
athleten und sport profis aus allen
teilen der welt an und organisieren
große internationale sportveranstaltung
und sie kauften sogar einfach einige der
bekanntesten teams der welt auf wir
sprechen von mannschaften wie paris oder
manchester city new york city fc den
wiederholten versuchen manchester united
zu kaufen oder der jüngsten übernahme
durch die saudische regierung
die saudi newcastle fußball übernahme
gibt anlass zu bedenken wegen sex
machine ist der jüngste staat der einen
westlichen sportverein aufkaufte um sein
image im ausland aufzubessern wie
experten meinen doch von allen
ölmonarchien am persischen golf ist
ausgerechnet katar in dieser
angelegenheit die weiter gegangen denn
wenn es um die sportindustrie geht
spielt katar einfach in einer ganz
anderen liga
[Musik]
katars große neuzugänge
mit einer bevölkerung von nur 350.000
katar an und zwei millionen einwanderern
ist katar eine kleine halbinsel im nahen
osten eine sehr sehr reiches land das
liegt vor allem daran dass sie der
weltweit größte exporteur von
flüssigerdgas kurz lng sind das land
versucht jedoch schon seit jahren seine
wirtschaft zu diversifizieren und um das
zu erreichen wurde 2008 die vision 2030
ins leben gerufen eine strategie einen
plan und katar zu allen entwickelten und
wetters wegen land jenseits der
kohlenwasserstoffe zu machen nun in
dieser strategie waren das sport und
insbesondere fußball herausragende
elemente dieses modernisierungsplan
das ziel war mit publikum sport den
tourismus das image car tax in der welt
und auch seinen politischen einfluss
anzukurbeln mit anderen worten sie
wollten den fußball an sich in eine
gigantische
werbekampagne verwandeln um dies zu
erreichen kaufte die katarische
regierung 2011 den größten fußballverein
frankreichs natürlich wurde die ankunft
der neuen eigentümer von einem riesigen
geldfluss begleitet und mit ihm kam eine
reihe von stars wie david beckham player
mvp di maria ramos und lionel messi
tatsächlich wurden die beiden teuersten
verpflichtungen in der geschichte des
fußballs von dieser mannschaft getätigt
ich spreche von der 252 millionen dollar
teuren verpflichtung von neymar und in
204 millionen dollar für endo das alles
damit psg ein echtes aushängeschild für
katar und seine aufstrebende fußball
industrie sein kann so wurde der
bsg-präsident wiederum zum präsidenten
der europäischen klub-vereinigung
ernannt eine position die ihn auch
direkt in den usa exekutivrat brachte
eine mehr als einflussreiche position
wenn es zb darum geht viele große
mannschaften dazu zu ermutigen
trainingszeiten im emirat zu verbringen
aber das ist noch nicht alles darüber
hinaus haben sie im laufe der jahre auch
ihre eigene nationale liga entwickelt
und genau das war die idee das
weltberühmte stars in qatar leben und so
zu botschaftern des landes werben und
hat das funktioniert nur sie selbst
kw erinnern der sd kritik an katar ist
unbegründet es ist ein großzügiges und
gastfreundliches land
david beckham unterzeichnet einen 150
millionen pfund vertrag als botschafter
für katar doch die größte
herausforderung kam 2010 mit der vergabe
der fußball-weltmeisterschaft 2022 die
scheichs hatten eine ganz klare
strategie dies da ihr ja der perfekte
moment und der welt das beste bild eines
modernen entwickelten und wohlhabenden
landes zu zeigen überleg mal was gibt es
besseres als wenn die ganze welt zusieht
und deswegen machten die scheiß nägel
mit köpfen
[Musik]
2010 haben sie einen riesigen
investitionsplan von fast 200 milliarden
dollar umgesetzt das emirat komplett
umgestaltet hat die u-bahn dem flughafen
neue autobahn tausende neue hotelzimmer
promenaden und sogar eine neue insel
statt los sei die etwa 15 kilometer von
dora entfernt liegt eine stadt mit ihren
wohngebieten einkaufszentren
luxusgeschäften stritten und zwei
golfplätzen sie ist halt der endphase
der fußball-wm und mindestens zehn jahre
lang wird die formel 1 dort beim großen
preis von katar ihre runden drehen und
natürlich sind unter den projekten
realisiert wurden auch einige der
modernsten stadien der welt darunter das
erste klimatisierte stadion um das erste
abbaubare stadion und mit dem jahr 2022
spricht nun jedes jahr an in dem all
diese wunde der welt präsentiert werden
soll das problem liebe freunde ist
allerdings dass die dinge inzwischen so
kompliziert geworden sind dass dieser
riesen schuss für das emirat gewaltig
nach hinten losgehen könnte könnte diese
weltmeisterschaft zu einem mega flop
werden nun genau das werden wir jetzt
ergründen
eine weltmeisterschaft unter verdacht
wenn man nur ein bisschen darüber
nachdenke städten relativ schnell fest
dass katar vielleicht einer der denkbar
schlechtesten austragungsorte einer
fußball weltmeisterschaft oder überhaupt
irgend eines großen internationalen
wettbewerbs ist denn es stimmt zwar dass
das land viele fortschritte gemacht hat
und mit vielen bereichen fast schon ein
vorbild in der region ist aber schauen
sie uns doch mal etwas genauer an wie
katar überhaupt eine internationale
bewerbung um die ausrichtung des
vielleicht wichtigsten sport wettbewerbs
der welt gewinnen konnte
denn trotz der vielen verbesserungen die
stattgefunden haben reden wir über ein
land mit sehr rauen klimatischen
bedingungen mit einer schlechten bilanz
bei der achtung der menschenrechte wo
die medien zensiert werden wo
homosexualität kriminalisiert wird und
wo frauen nicht gleichberechtigt mit
männern sind zu allem überfluss wurde im
november 2010 in einem technischen
bericht der fifa festgestellt dass katar
der einzige kandidat war der als
gastgeber hohe operationelle risiken
aufwies
dies lag unter anderem daran dass eine
für die ausrichtung eines so großen
events notwendige infrastruktur noch
nicht mal ansatzweise vorhanden war wenn
du all diese dinge berücksichtigt und
bedenkt dass es sich bei den
konkurrenten katar sinn überaus starke
und attraktive kandidaten die japan die
usa südkorea oder neuseeland handelte
was ich sage ist nicht links ist ein
bisschen merkwürdig dass ausgerechnet
katar ausgewählt wurde was meinst du die
entscheidung für katar bedeutete sogar
dass der gesamte welt fußball kalender
auf den kopf gestellt werden musste und
warum nun auf gute extrem harten
wetterbedingungen sehr heiß und feucht
muss die weltmeisterschaft in den
monaten november und dezember
stattfinden was eine komplette
unterbrechung der wichtigsten ligen der
welt bedeutet la liga die premier league
die seria die bundesliga und so weiter
und so fort warum genau haben sich die
fifa oberen trotzdem für katar
entschieden nun sagen wir einfach dass
schon damals mit der ankündigung die
theorien dazu und damals konnte man sie
noch verschwörungstheorien nennen nur so
aus dem boden sprießen seitdem sind aber
schon elf jahre vergangen und in dieser
zeit sind so manche beweise aufgetaucht
oder sagen wir mal lieber sehr viele
beweise erdrückend viele beweise
blatter und platini werden in der fifa
korruption untersuchung wegen betrugs
angeklagt den ehemaligen chefs des welt
und europa fußball werden von den
schweizer behörden beschuldigt
bestechungsgelder in höhe von 2
millionen dollar erhalten zu haben seit
der vergabe der
fußball-weltmeisterschaft und katar sind
viele beweise und zeugenaussagen
aufgetaucht die auf massive korruption
im wahlprozess hinweisen ein bisschen
blauer beschuldigte zb in kameruner issa
hayatou und den ivorer jacques anouma
jeweils 15 millionen dollar im tausch
für eine stimme für katar erhalten zu
haben dann wurde mohamed bin hammam der
präsident des asiatischen fußball
föderation ein starker kandidat für die
fifa-präsidentschaft beschuldigt 25
funktionäre bestochen zu haben damit sie
für kataster und tatsächlich wurde er
nach diesen enthüllungen auf lebenszeit
gesperrt und das liebe freunde sind nur
zwei von vielen beispielen
[Musik]
im jahr 2012 wurde die tiefe angesichts
der vielen skandale wegen angeblicher
korruption durch michael garcia
untersucht garcia ist ein ehemaliger new
yorker anwalt und richter der den
vorsitz der fifa ethikkommission hatte
zwei jahre lang führte eine gründliche
untersuchung durch deren ergebnisse auf
350 seiten als garcia bericht bekannt
[Musik]
die fifa beschloss jedoch den
detaillierten bericht lieber in der
schublade verschwinden zu lassen und nur
eine geschönte zusammenfassung zu
veröffentlichen die niemanden belasten
würde daraufhin trat michael gasser aus
protest von seinem amt zurück und wisst
ihr was heißt der komplette bericht
jahre später dann doch durchgesickert
ist standen darin so offensichtliche
dinge wie dass die mitglieder des
exekutivkomitees welche die negativen
aspekte der bewerbung katars
untersuchten nicht einmal die rauen
wetterbedingungen oder die unterbrechung
des weltfussball kalenders
berücksichtigt haben ganz und gar nicht
die augen wurden ganz fest zugedrückt
katar musste um jeden preis gewinnen
nach einer vielzahl von anschuldigungen
der verhaftung von 11 funktionieren
durch das sb ein jahr 2015 nie der
korruption beschuldigt wurden und an der
abstimmung zur unterstützung badoers
teilgenommen hatten konnte uns wohl alle
ein bild von den motiven machen welche
dieses inserat wirklich zum sieger
gemacht haben außerdem wurde 2009 10
bekannt dass al jazira 400 millionen
dollar für die sicherung der
fernsehrechte des turniers geboten hatte
plus weitere 100 millionen dollar falls
katar den zuschlag erhält
[Musik]
[Applaus]
tja was soll ich sagen so tickt die fifa
aber das ist nicht der einzige
fragwürdige aspekt der weltmeisterschaft
in katar die unmenschlichen bedingungen
unter denen billiglohn migranten in
katar arbeiten sind ein weiterer grund
für kontroversen mehr als
6500 arbeits bekannten aus indien
pakistan bangladesch und sri lanka sind
in katar während der arbeit gestorben
seit das emirat vor zehn jahren den
zuschlag für die fußball
weltmeisterschaft erhalten hat die
meisten von ihnen starten zwar nicht auf
den stadionbau stellen direkt aber im
rahmen der infrastruktur projekte die in
zusammenhang mit der fußball wm in katar
notwendig sind
die brütende hitze fehlende
sicherheitsmaßnahmen oder das kv system
welches die arbeiter aus armen ländern
quasi zu sklaven machte heute aber zum
glück nicht mehr angewendet wird waren
sicherlich die hauptursachen für all
diese tragödie bei einem kaffee das
system ist der arbeitnehmer rechtlich
vollkommen vom arbeitgeber abhängig so
dass man sogar die zustimmung des chefs
braucht wenn man als gastarbeiter aus
katar wieder ausreisen möchte das hat
zur folge dass sich die arbeitnehmer
nicht beschweren und auch nicht den
arbeitsplatz wechseln können die firmen
können so die arbeitsbedingungen nach
ihrem gusto diktieren um noch einmal auf
die 6500 todesopfer zurückzukommen es
muss klar sein dass dies für ein so
reiches land erschreckende zahlen sind
erstaunlicherweise haben sie doch den
herkunftsländern der gastarbeiter gar
nicht mal für so großes aufsehen gesorgt
warum nun weil nach angaben der
indischen regierung die sterblichkeit
während der berufsausübung dort noch
viel höher ist als in katar
[Musik]
dabei darf man aber nicht vergessen in
den beta armes land es kann sich bessere
arbeitsbedingungen und höhere
arbeitssicherheit oft gar nicht leisten
beim emirat katar haben wir es jedoch
mit einem der reichsten länder der welt
zu tun von dem man eben etwas ganz
anderes erwarten kann diese hohe
sterblichkeit am arbeitsplatz die
sklaven artigen verhältnisse die
schrecklichen lebensbedingungen und die
sehr lange arbeitszeiten haben viele
internationale organisationen dazu
veranlasst diese weltmeisterschaft als
weltmeisterschaft der schande
anzuprangern keine fußball-wm zuvor
musste sich den vorwurf gefallen lassen
bereits vor dem ersten anpfiff 6500
menschen das leben gekostet zu haben das
ist so viel wie eine kleine stadt voller
leichen unglaublich so was im jahr 2022
möglicherweise haben die heftige kritik
und der massive druck der
weltöffentlichkeit dazu geführt dass
katar seinen gesamten arbeit
vorschriften von grund auf überarbeitet
hat es hat sozialstandards eingeführt
und den perversen cover system ein ende
gesetzt zumindest etwas positives was
diese weltmeisterschaft bereits gebracht
hat
natürlich darf man nicht vergessen dass
auch die massive kritik an katar kein
werk gewissenhafter politiker
medienmacher oder gar sportfunktionäre
aus dem westen ist nein verantwortlich
dafür ist der medien krieg zwischen den
regierungen katars auf der einen und den
vereinigten arabischen emiraten und
saudi arabien auf der anderen seite die
ivg und die saudis versuchen natürlich
mit allen mitteln das image qatars in
der welt zu beschädigen und da kommt
jeder skandal rund um die wm gerade
recht die katarer sind deswegen nun ganz
besonders auf der hut denn ein scheitern
der wm wird als der größte schlag
angesehen denn das emirat rote erleiden
könnte vielleicht noch schlimmer als ein
überfall das audis und die moral von der
geschicht trauer politikern und
funktionären nicht sondern kontrolliere
sie und lasst sie sich gegenseitig in
schach halten denn auf der welt und vor
allem in der politik gibt es nur selten
etwas absolut gutes oder böses jede
regierung jeder politiker und eigentlich
jeder mitmacht liegt irgendwo dazwischen
wie sehr er sich der einen oder der
anderen seite zeigt hängt dabei vor
allem davon ab wie beobachtet und
bedroht er sich fühlt deswegen ist
transparenz sehr wichtig und natürlich
konkurrenz da man keine politiker trauen
darf ist es wichtig sie miteinander
konkurrieren zu lassen damit sie sich so
ganz natürlich gegenseitig überwachen
und das gilt natürlich auch für ganze
regierungen weder katar noch
saudi-arabien sind besonders
sympathische und humanistische regimes
in diesem fall hat jedoch die konkurrenz
zwischen ihnen dafür gesorgt dass qatar
sich zu verbesserungen gezwungen sah du
hast vorstellung man könne sich bei der
weltöffentlichkeit ein modernes image
verpassen indem man es sich nur mit viel
geld und viel korruption kauft ohne im
inneren wirklich modern zu werden wurde
vor allem durch die vw- und die saudis
durchkreuzt nicht weil sie selbst
moderne wären oder ihnen das schicksal
der gastarbeiter am herzen liegen würde
sondern einfach nur um ihren
konkurrenten das leben schwer zu machen
wenn zwei schlechte sie hauen kann also
durchaus etwas gutes dabei herauskommen
und das liebe diese politik fans waren
die ursachen die qatar zur teuersten wm
aller zeiten gemacht haben was denkst du
wer diese weltmeisterschaft gewinnen
wird wird es für die interessen kattas
so gut laufen wie die regierung in doha
hofft was könnte jetzt noch schief gehen
und was denkst du über die fifa wie
könnte man den dortigen markt
austrocknen wie immer sind sie auf eure
meinungen zu diesem thema hochgradig
gespannt ich hoffe also dass euch dieses
video gefallen hat was ja geht uns mit
deinen leisten und freuen und vergesst
nicht dass ab mit glöckchen um keines
unserer videos mehr zu verpassen
unterstützt unsere arbeit bitte auch mit
einer kleinen spende über den link in
der beschreibung unter diesem video was
gut und bis bald
[Musik]